all right so we got a city of walls and
secrets isn't this kind of a messed up
episode a lot of respects they get to
the city edges some good set up jokes in
this one actually I like when they're
going to the city of Ba Sing se the
right busting oh you know the city any
hoop actually it's right there boss Sing
se oh it's close its close to close
family so uh they're going to the city
they're taking service trained I'm not
entirely sure how that works looks like
two earth benders are pushing it but how
are they doing the ad doesn't okay so
they're going to the city and they say I
can't believe we actually made it in
sockets as oh come on we could get there
and it could be destroyed or maybe it's
underwater or maybe something will come
and stop us before we get there again
they're the very smart to serve read
into their tropes and they're kind of
continuing I don't want to say cliches
but an tropes we'll just go with tropes
uh and then there's another really great
joke I thought this was so funny when
they say they're gonna see the Kings
bear I see leave me like platypus bear
no skunk bear no cat there no just bear
hey look at your and say this place is
weird wonderful joke I mean just totally
setting up this very bizarre world where
everything is a mix between animals and
then here's one animal that's just one
thing yeah they think that's the oddity
it's very smart very very clever okay so
they get to this place and everything
seems to be the people that run the play
seem to be very smiling very happy to a
very creepy degree they're always sort
of smiling they're always sort of
cheerful people seem to disappear who
disagree or question things and as it
goes on we find out that the King they
want to see to tell them about the
cliffs and how this can be a great
advantage
is not actually available until a month
or a month and a half down the line this
obviously has to be gotten to them
pretty fast so they try to sneak their
way in the talk to them and they find
out the king actually doesn't deal with
this kind of stuff there's another guy
who deals with it and even he is very
skeptical he's more about just keeping
the quiet keeping it so that there's not
even a war that exists inside the wall
now of course there was a giant battle
that happened outside the wall the
previous episode but nobody inside the
city was aware of this and you can buy
that because they make this city very
large which is impressive to show
because all the RCS they've been to in
towns they've shown them very impressive
size and they make this probably the
biggest town they've been to the biggest
city and again just a good angle good a
good shopping out that just showed the
size of this show is very good at
showing the the scope and size of where
they are and it's to a point where
anyone that questions whether or not
there's a war or any kind of violence or
threatening or it just really
questioning the government at all is
taken away in silenced pretty much and
we don't exactly know what happens to
them either the the tour guys showing
them around is later replaced but given
the same name and this other one comes
in that's just a smiley and cheerful
it's just like ooh that's the note it
ends on so that's those delightfully
creepy um so I mean it's it's nice the
good little sort of commentary on you
knows our keeping ourselves very shelter
and how far people will go to keep them
so sheltered and what society will sort
of let get away with um and then you had
the other story again with Zuko and jet
which again just doesn't go where I
wanted it to go as or it looks like just
a big way of showing what this
government can do
with people who question things or
distribute or display violence
so pretty much jet is just a pawn it
seems like to be taken away hypnotized
and turned into one of them um no great
development with him or Zuko but you
know whatever whatever I mean it's not
like that was like the core of the show
or anything but yeah you know yeah what
can you do uh I guess do co and the
uncle serve had to be I mean they're
they're like waiters now pretty much and
they're tea makers and again which I
like I mean you could they could plane
it up for more laughs in the sense of
all look Zuko as to wear an apron haha
but they really don't I mean they keep
the humor where it is with with the
uncle who of course loves tea and he
loves the art of making the tea and I I
give credit to both the characters that
there's two times where they could use
the firebending but they don't one is
when the uncle could use it to turn on
the stove jet steel some sort of stone
or something to turn it on and the uncle
goes and gets something from the
neighbor and then of course when Jeff
comes to say use your firebending power
fight me fight me he never does so I
like that I like that they used the
restraint there I thought that was a
pretty cool especially after Zuko he
yells at the uncle in the previous
episode for using it to heat the tea up
which was pretty stupid the uncles part
Oh
so I'm trying to think what else um I
mean it's it's good and it's I feel like
I've kind of seen this kind of stuff
before with the the controlling Big
Brother element of nothing is wrong
everything is happy so it's nothing
phenomenally new but it'll be
interesting to see what they do with it
um and whether or not and and how much
power the King actually has if he if
he's even real what they brought about
he almost looks like a statue
that'd be interesting it's like just a
puppet or something um so it's
interesting in the aspect of I like to
see what they do with it now that we're
given this information so we'll see
where that goes uh surprisingly not much
else I can think about to say with this
episode ooh you think I'd be able to say
it done with like the commentary and
stuff like that but I feel always seen
this stuff before and it's good to see
it a show like this and especially with
a city that is so large you know the
bigger someplace gets sort of the more
the more out of control can get thus the
more control those who run things feel
it needs to be kept in and the more they
need to lie and the more they need to
manipulate to keep something so large
under control so it's it's interesting
and it's a good episode I mean there's
nothing really bad per se about it
um and as always I'm curious to see what
they're gonna do with it uh but yeah I
guess I can't think too much else to say
about because we sort of again this guy
count Terry's been done before um but
it's it's decent it's a still decent
episode so uh yeah tune in for the next
episode cuz actually my brother was
saying like you know what when you get
to uh what's it called again all the
tales of bossing say well when he gets
had episode I really want to come in on
that one so you'll probably see him on
the next episode as well I'll call him
him for that one so um yeah that's about
it and I'll see you at the next one with
my brother till then